so as the title says I think the last
episode of House of the Dragon was a
little overwhelming because of the pace
the show is moving however the quality
of the scenes that make up the episode
are still really good especially in
regards to the crazy plot beats
engrossing characters acting production
value and really everything it's just
how fast the story is being told and how
much setup we are getting before the
payoff before we get into that further I
want to start at the beginning of the
episode and talk about some of the
newcomers Emma DRC plays older runera is
really being put to the test by having
to do a very long take of childbirth I
think that's a stellar way to introduce
us to the new actor and immediately
commands the respect of the viewer
because of how impressive the scene was
Millie was a gem of an actor but I think
wearing good hands going forward as
evidenced by this scene not only does
Emma DRC have to show us the Pains of
childbirth and all that Agony but she
has to add a layer to that performance
and show us how much of a nuisance
Allison is that quick moment of dread as
she clutches her baby shows us her
moment of Happiness was ruined and
allows the audience to instantly
sympathize with her then her decision to
take the baby herself was a staggering
power move that again makes us love
renera as a character in an age where so
many shows and movies bashed feministic
messages over your head as if your
hordor trying to understand She-Hulk
having a character make natural
decisions that in turn make some more
Brave likable and realistic feels
refreshing and amazing I don't want to
be spoon-fed dumb messages and themes
that you want to push as a writer but
instead be entranced by lovable
characters that progress the story into
logical and exciting Manner and I even
love the attention to detail within this
scene for two different aspects the
audio of the baby coming out was so
slimy and disgusting and made this seem
very realistic and honestly I would play
it for the memes but I don't know if it
would get me demonetized andranera's
Blood Trail was also a nice touch the
scene after the childbirth is also
another long wonderer and I love him for
doing this firstly it really accentuates
we're near a struggle on this moment
because we're with her the entire way of
her journey through the red keep it also
introduces us to our Nero and lehner's
relationship and how much they dislike
each other but they still kind of
tolerate one another another aspect that
I adore in this scene is that Miguel is
showing off the pure scale of the set
that was made for the interior of the
red keep if anyone doesn't know HBO
essentially made most of the red keep
from scratch and it can walk from room
to room seamlessly this long take
perfectly showcases it here and it's not
only to boast about how big the set
piece is but it also works as a riveting
character moment then we have good old
sir Kristen Cole show up again I'm still
kind of sad that we don't see any
aftermath of episode 5 because I want
them to clear up the confusion of if
there was any consequences to killing
Joffrey I would assume there would be
some questioning and I know that Allison
probably wants to keep him on the
kingsguard given that he's a good asset
for her but if Kristen is corroborating
a lie that Joffrey pulled a knife or
something and that is why he killed him
then wouldn't that further taint his
honor that he cares so much about I
don't know I still think the character
is interesting and its General Arc is
going to create some cool conflict it's
just the execution of it felt rushed
confusing and needed some time to
breathe after the fact instead of doing
a 10-year time Jump but moving on to
Allison she's really been marinating in
her hatred for the last 10 years and the
competitive fires that Otto Hightower
stoked in episode 5 are really coming to
fruition here I wish we got to see some
of that build up instead of jumping into
the new version of the character that we
were already engaged in but for the new
actress I think Olivia Cook so far is
matching the quality of Emily Carey and
is still really expressive in scenes
that wouldn't seem that emotional at
face value our good old pal visceros is
still kicking around and sadly he's lost
his left arm I think it would be really
funny if he somehow made it to the end
of the season but that probably won't
happen his willful ignorance in the
scene is on Full display a it is even
ironic when he says that the baby has
laner's nose I guess he's just entirely
ignoring the fact that our kids have
black hair despite Lenor nornira having
silver hair I mean come on even that
Stark put two and two together and I
also like how most people know about
this situation it is a constant
festering issue that is going to explode
at any minute this essentially again
stems into the fact of pacing because we
just got introduced to Sir Harwin strong
in our nearest relationship with him
only for it to be ripped away like
imagine if we came to love saharwin as
being a wholesome dad and had to
struggle with the conflict of having to
contain his love for his children and
keep that a secret that seems like a
great Dynamic but it's largely skipped
over so we can quickly get through the
story the main point of there being
built up is for the audience to form an
emotional bond with characters and in
fewer scenes it's hard to really Forge
that Bond and care about them so when
they die their deaths don't feel that
impactful besides just moving along the
store worry like I feel like I would be
a lot sadder for Star Harmon's death if
we had like more than two scenes of him
interacting with his children in
rhaenyra but sadly we don't get to
witness that another example within the
episode is the death of Lena valerion we
get like three scenes with her and Damon
and I was genuinely interested in Damon
actually settling down and kind of
raising a family and the conflicts
associated with that especially since in
the last episode he killed his wife so
going from that to him suddenly being
married and having kids feels jarring
because we are leaving out the middle
part of that development now again the
scenes here are still good and well made
and in particular I love the scene where
Lena asks vegar to kill her it's really
tragic and saddening to see the
hesitation and confusion within the
dragon trying to comprehend why her
Rider wants to kill herself but
emotionally in the scene I wasn't that
sad because we just got introduced to
Lane and Damon's relationship if we had
more time to grow an attachment to their
relationship then the scene would be
significant more depressing that would
be like Daenerys just marrying caldrego
and then within the same episode he gets
poisoned and dies now that relationship
is obviously more integral to the story
of Game of Thrones but you still need
time for the audience to care about
these characters same thing for sir
Harwin strong you can do that in a small
amount of time but the more build up you
have the stronger the impact will be
since I haven't read the books I don't
know what they are technically skipping
over and if there was a Content drought
and that was why they did a major time
Jump but by doing this you essentially
have to reintroduce us to everyone again
and as the Creator said it's basically
like a second pilot episode in one
season in six we have the time Jump and
the changeover of actors and it felt
like a second pilot instead to me it
would make more sense to slow down and
naturally progress the story and do what
they did within the first five episodes
and occasionally Flash Forward like one
to three years at a time if they really
needed to and from my understanding it
seems like HBO just wanted to do the
dance of the Dragons but George R Martin
probably insisted on doing the 20 years
beforehand to set everything up so it
comes across as them trying to cram that
20ish years into the first season alone
to combat this maybe they should have
done that 20 years over the course of
two seasons and at worst they could have
done two shortened Seasons before the
dance or one longer season would it kill
them to give us more than 10 episodes
come on because currently the pace for
me is borderlining on ludicrous speeds
and I find it ironic that some people
are saying that the show is boring like
what do you mean there are major
Revelations twists and deaths happening
in almost every episode you don't need
that to make the show great and Game of
Thrones heavily relied on
character-centric scenes that was mostly
composed of dialogue and had very little
plot development so at the end of the
day this is my opinion and if you're
fine with the pace then that's A-Okay
because to me the scenes are still
really good and they're not bad by any
means since I'm kind of done going on
about the pacing let's talk about some
more of the highlights within episode 6.
I think the kids being showcased are
really interesting and I like the
direction that aegon is going seeing a
completely spoiled Targaryen child that
seemingly has no remorse will make for a
very entertaining adult later on I've
seen some people compare him to
homelander from the boys and I really
hope that's where he's going at first I
thought it it was a little bit much for
him to be jerking off out the window but
it quickly and efficiently sets up who
he is as a character then and it gives
more of a meaning to the name King's
Landing it's not just Thomas corpse
falling onto the people and instead some
sticky rain it was also nice to see the
dragon pit and I especially love the
grizzled dragon Keepers that was helping
reniera's children this guy's voice was
immensely satisfying
then another great scene was the
courtyard combat training there were so
many layers here due to the amount of
characters that were featured in the
amount of perspectives being shown we
see sir Christians disdain towards
Rainier's children in the favoritism
towards Allison's children sir Harwin
clearly getting upset as if he's a dad
on the sideline of a sports match
getting mad at the coach for benching
his kids King visery is just vibing and
being happy and most of the kids getting
a quick moment to shine then the end of
the scene ends perfectly and is a great
setup for what happens when later on I
love the inner turmoil going on within
Lino strong and how truly loyal he is to
King of his Terrace but struggles to
tell the truth of Sir Harwin that
scenery tries to retire was so painful
to watch because you know you can't say
the hard truth it made the scene even
better that Allison knew exactly what
Lionel was talking about but was just
losing her mind in the background at
this point I assumed that viserys knows
but he doesn't want to dodge up any
conflict and just wants everyone to be
happy and this leads into the chaos that
his letter is strong now this man is a
flat out love child of Littlefinger and
Varys I was not expecting this seemingly
innocent character who was hanging out
with the ladies eating snacks in episode
3 to be a psychotic murderer who kills
his family again I wish we had a little
more build up as to what he's been doing
in King's Landing with Allison in their
relationship but I think it was still
executed well since it's supposed to
come as a shock to the audience and
Allison's that's really setting up an
interesting Direction because Allison is
in the deep end now and she does not
want to piss off Laris he's very
intimidating despite him not physically
looking so and that's mostly just a big
Applause to his unsettling performance I
also like the small detail of his Beetle
being associable to his character and
his evil servants makes them more
visually recognizable and you instantly
know their affiliation overall I still
really adore episode 6 despite the
pacing being pretty fast I think the
show does do a good job to combat that
feeling of a fast pace by having really
long and intriguing dialogue scenes so
we aren't rapidly moving between scenes
if they were able to make a happy
compromise with that and not skipping so
much time then I think the pace would be
perfect thank you for watching and I'm
about to be hit by a hurricane so
hopefully I don't die or lose power for
a long time and I can still make videos
but regardless let me know in the
comments what you thought about episode
6. foreign